دخل قائد قوات الحمايه الاشعاعيه
والكيميائيه الروسيه من الولايات المتحده
تخطط بالتعاون مع شركائها لتنفيذ استفزاز
في اوكرانيا باستخدام مواد كيميائيه سامه
واضاف انه في حاله حدوث استفزاز من قبل
الغرب باستخدام مواد كيميائيه سامه في
اوكرانيا سيتم تحديد الجنات الحقيقيين من
قبل وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ومعاقبتهم
الى كراماتوس العاشر من الشهر الجاري كان
يحمل شحنه مواد كيميائيه
المتحدث باسم الكريم
خطه الصين لتسويه الازمه في اوكرانيا
والتي طرحتها بجين خلال زياره رئيس لجنه
الشؤون الخارجيه في اللجنه المركزيه للحزب
الشيوعي الصيني
الى روسيا الاسبوع الماضي تتماجى مع نهج
موسكو مشيرا الى ان المعاني الدقيقه في
الاقتراح مهمه واضاف بسكوب في مقابله مع
صحيفه الروسيه ان الرئيس وادي كان وما زال
منفتحا على اي اتصالات من شانها ان تحقق
اهداف روسيا باي طريقه واوضحها
النوويه
الى حين استماع واشنطن الى موقف موسكو
اما في كيف فقال رئيس المخابرات
الاوكرانيه كريلو بودان نوفل انه لا توجد
مؤشرات وحقائق ملموسه على ان الصين تناقش
تزويد اوكرانيا بالسلاح
لقائد مع اذاعه صوت امريكا نصين لن توافق
على نقل الاسلحه الى روسيا
تكون هناك معلومات عن تزويد كوريا
الشماليه لروسيا بالاسلحه
ولفتين ان الدوله الوحيده تقريبا التي
تنقل بالفعل اسلحه لروسيا هي ايران
الى رفض الصربيه تقديم الاسلحه الى روسيا
رغم انها كانت تعول عليها وان روسيا تسعى
للحصول على اسلحه من اي مكان لتجاوز الحظر
وتجري مباحثات حول ذلك مع ميانوار
انظر
الجزيره حسان مسعود ومن موسكو ينضم الينا
مراسل الجزيره ايمن الزبير
تقول انها تحاول المحافظه على مواقعها في
بخموت وفاغنر تقول ميليشيايف انها تحكم
السيطره او تقترب من السيطره الكامله
نعم عثمان تفاصيل عن الواقع عند جبهه بخمه
تحدثت عنها قياده القوات البريه
الاوكرانيه عندما قالت ان الوضع هناك
متوتر للغايه
وذكرت ان قوات فاجنر وان كانت
يتم اصابتها
وتتكبد خسائر كبيره بشريه خلال محاولاتها
الهجوم الا انها تستخدم افضل قواتها واكثر
قواتها
استعدادا وتدريبا في محاوله اختراق صفوف
دفاعات القوات الاوكرانيه ومحاصره مدينه
باخموت وفق اخر التصريحات لقياده القوات
البريه الا ان قياده الاركان ايضا ذكرت ان
القوات الاوكرانيه تصدت ل 60 هجوما عند
الجبهات الشرقيه
وتحدثت عن القوات الاوكرانيه التقدم او
الروسيه التقدم عند اكثر من جبهه في شرق
اوكرانيا وانها تتصدى لهذه الهجمات وتكبد
ايضا القوات الروسيه خسائر
القياده الاوكرانيه كانت تتحدث عن مئات
القتلى من القوات الروسيه المهاجمه
وتحديدا من قوات فاجنر الى انها تشير بشكل
واضح الى صعوبه الاوضاع على الجبهه وهذا
هذه التصريحات تاتي بالتزامن ايضا مع
تصريحات اخرى تتحدث فيها القياده
الاوكرانيه وتحديدا على لسان رئيس
الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه عن الاستعداد
للفتره المقبله لثلاثه اشهر القادمه والتي
ستشهد تغيرا على الواقع وستحدد مسار
المعارك وفقه رئيس الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه
كريلي و بودانوف الذي اكد على ان
الاوكرانيون يستعدون لهجوم على محور
دانياتك وكذلك في مختلف الاتجاهات على
الجبهات المختلفه في اوكرانيا ايمن
تحذيرات روسيه من استفزاز غربي كيميائي
وتلويح
بالرد ما الدلائل التي قدمتها موسكو في
هذا الخصوص
نعم وسيله دعنا نبدا بمجموعه من التطورات
التي شهدتها روسيا في الساعات الاخيره كان
اخرها الاعلان عن اغلاق مطار سان
بيترسبورغ الى غايه منتصف النهار لم يتم
الى حدود الساعه ايضاح الاسباب ايضا كان
هناك تطور لافت في شمال
عقوقاز في في بلده اديغا تحديدا سقطت
طائره مسيره هذا الحادث ما زال قيد
التحقيق ولكن
اهميه هذا التطور هو كون هذه المنطقه تبعد
بمئه كيلومتر عن مدينه كراش نودار الروسيه
وب500 كيلومتر تقريبا عن المناطق التي
تسيطر عليها القوات الاوكرانيه ايضا كان
كانت لافته تصريحات المسؤول عن الدفاع
الكيميائي في وزاره
الروسيه التي تحدث عن استفزاز محتمل
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وشركائها دليله او حجته في ذلك هي تصريحات
المسؤول او السفير السابق للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هنا في موسكو الذي تحدث
عن
نيه القوات الروسيه
باقامه او تنفيذ هجوم كيميائي على على بعض
المناطق وهذا يوضح حسب المسؤول الروسي ان
هناك
نيه مبيته عفوا لدى السلطات
الامريكيه بتنفيذ هذا الهجوم اعطى معطيات
دقيقه تحدث عن وصول عربات محمله باسلحه
كيميائيه الى محطه قطارات كراماتور يوم
العاشر من فبراير وقال ان السلطات الروسيه
ستحدد الجولات في حال وقوع هذا
الهجوم نعم شكرا شكرا جزيلا لكم
وحسان مسعود منكيف